hey 42 here Kim il-sung's grandson Jeong
Nam was sucked as heir to North Korea
after being arrested trying to enter
Japan on a false passport to visit
Disneyland welcome to RIF when customers
visited the UK's first supermarkets they
were afraid to pick up goods in case
they were told up since smoking was
banned in 2004 the main currency in US
prisons is mackerel it was 33 years
after loo paper was invented in Green
Bay Wisconsin that it could finally be
advertised as splinter free the shortest
war ever fought was between Britain and
Zanzibar on August 27th 1896 Zanzibar
surrendered after 38 minutes kestrels
can locate voles from the sky because of
ultraviolet light reflected by their URI
bubble-wrap was first produced in a New
Jersey garage in 1957 its inventors were
trying to make easy white textured
wallpaper between 1917 and 1940 the cure
for patients with syphilis was to give
them malaria since its discovery in 1930
Pluto has traveled only a third of its
way around the Sun the proud owner of
the first silicone breast implant was a
dog called Esmeralda Nelson Mandela was
not removed from the u.s. terror
watchlist until 2008 almost half of all
Americans today are classified as living
in poverty 46 percent pay no income tax
the word hundred is derived from the
word puddin Draft
which actually means
hundred-and-twenty not a hundred sucking
a king's nipples was a gesture of
submission in ancient Ireland
in Japan Tintin is called tan tongue
because Tintin is pronounced chin chin
and means penis thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42